this week it was all laid bare public
hearings partisan posturing nothing new
what a farce let's start shall we by
enjoying for a moment the laughable
hypocrisy of the Democrats latest
desperate impeachment gambit apparently
is about bribery now Nancy Pelosi said
so and they all fell in line like sheep
the bribe is to grant or withhold
military assistance in return for a
public statement of a of a fake
investigation into the elections that's
that's bribery bribery bribery bribery
bribery bribery bribery and bribery
bribery bribery are they kidding in the
swamp
bribery is their business model what do
you think a political donation from a
business or a lobbyist or corporate PAC
is its money in exchange for a political
favor it's a bribe let's pick some
random examples oh look Adam Schiff he
took over three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in bribes from the
defense sector and surprise surprise
pushed for military action overseas
shift took over a hundred thousand
dollars from AT&T when it was reported
that President Trump wanted to block the
AT&T Time Warner merger
guess who piped up on AT&T x' behalf
shifty Schiff of course how about Jerry
Nadler he was bribed by lobbyists for
Somalia and a motley assortment of other
foreign governments he took over $80,000
from teachers unions in an exchange
voted against charter schools and
voucher programs and then the queen of
bribery Nancy Pelosi she boasts about
her fundraising prowess raising money is
the way she clings to power her office
proudly told the New York Times earlier
this year that she's raised over 700
million dollars since 2002 does anyone
think that money is anything other than
bribes
it worked for Visa in the 2008 cycle
they gave over a hundred thousand
dollars to Democrats on top of the fact
that Nancy herself snagged some
preferential stock in the company those
bribes helped persuade Pelosi as Speaker
of the House to kill off legislation
that would have cut visas revenues and
then there's the foreign bribes
including unn
leave ibly the fact that Pelosi has
taken money from lobbyists representing
shady companies in Ukraine my god
bribery thy name is Nancy so what did
the Democrats achieve this week with
their impeachment rebranding and public
parade of disgruntled bureaucrats
it wasn't damaging to President Trump as
they'd planned it actually hurt the
ruling class and the establishment who
have declared war on President Trump
because it exposed for all to see their
snooty arrogance and contempt for
democracy this was Bill Taylor the
current Ukraine ambassador I am NOT here
to take one side or the other that is
highly revealing and completely false
of course they take one side they take
the establishment side the bureaucracy
side the ruling class side this is not
about Republican versus Democrat
this is insiders versus the outsider
that's why they're so obsessed with
whether things are irregular encountered
an irregular informal channel of us
policymaking than a regular Channel it's
extremely irregular this irregular
Channel highly irregular highly
irregular
that's bureaucrat for deplorable that's
what this is all about it's this system
striking back Trump wants a state
department that stands up for America in
the world
they want to keep it standing up for the
world in America Trump thinks promises
made before an election should be
implemented after an election they want
to ignore those promises as if the
election never happened
Trump wanted to govern they chose to
obstruct Trump wants reelection they
won't take the risk but does the Trump
hating ruling class even understand how
much long-term damage is doing to
America's fabric with its reckless
demented drive to remove Donald Trump by
non democratic means because they're
worried he'll win an actual election
they destroyed trust in the media long
ago but now they've destroyed trust in
the civil service too in the Foreign
Service in the FBI the CIA the whole
system they've made sure future
presidents can't have
financial conversations with foreign
leaders they've distracted and divided
the country and they've guaranteed that
their next Democrat president will also
be impeached
I hear people all the time saying how
can you support Trump look at his
behavior look at his tweets I say look
at his results working Americans finally
getting a pay rise after decades of
income stagnation engineered by the same
establishment geniuses blocking Trump's
every move America's number-one enemy
China finally confronted after decades
of sucking up by the same establishment
geniuses now plotting to kick Trump out
and then look at Trump's enemies however
bad some people think Trump may be his
enemies are worse they are completely
insufferable pompous sanctimonious
self-righteous they're decadent doing
just fine in their coastal enclaves Oh
screw everyone else their superficial
always putting style over substance and
they are oblivious to the damage they
themselves did to this country with
their elitist policy agenda and the
damage they're doing now with their
divisive impeachment agenda the
Democrats talk about justice I tell you
what justice looks like these crazed
partisan Democrats sent to the political
wilderness their candidates defeated at
every level the White House Congress
state and local government until they
returned finally to their senses right
tell me what you think of that at Steve
Hilton X and that next Rev fnc